I don't look for more new details you
miss okay every technique exactly doing
this we're going to isolate goodbye
aspects of the technique together okay
so he's going to push and I am going to
he's gonna help me so you can think of
good guess
as the calibration to it okay so he's
not going to do this he's actually
trying to help me find in this case
we'll look for the back foot you guys
understand that so I'm going to
incrementals push into that back foot
okay
and you can take advantage of your own
training time by when you're you get you
are pushing from the back foot do you
see that so you're not starting to push
with your shoulders
okay so he is calibrating me and if I
feel myself starting to break I'll tell
them right but he should be able to feel
it so he's pushing right and if he feels
me OBC he'll these up a little bit to
help me find that okay
and as we're calibrating as I start to
find the back foot I can do this
anything I can tell him to push more and
as I'm telling them to push more I am
also trying to relax more okay you'll
feel areas bite
and we'll do the other side
you can see I'm not leaning on him I'm
just letting him wait my back foot and
as I feel that back foot really starting
to push down that's where I go back up
my body and start relaxing saying
starting with that back lower foot and
leg coming up to the pelvis relaxing it
without changing its shape just
releasing it releasing it
[Music]
okay and you'll switch every two because
you can start see the entire
[Music]
watch the crown of your head in the
beginning
[Music]
so too much arm been in the beginning is
going to activate your bicep try not to
do that extend a little more there you
go
stick with your basic in the beginning
katate dori shape arm
bring your hand down a little so it's
not a trick on the bracing angle on the
elbow extend your arm more to get out of
your bicep
[Music]
give it a slight Bend keep the other
side of your body alive
know some things to look for I this is
not a good day hey try to try to keep
yourself as close to your faces as
possible alright so you see my heart is
shaking because this is hinging okay so
I he's got to help me you kind of
pushing that way if you pay attention
but go ahead it's fine that's why I
because I'm relaxed you see how my arm
is taking that shape but he can't go
ahead you do what you were doing run it
go ahead and go that way so same thing I
am projecting this force down I am NOT
pushing out on it it would be impossible
do you understand like I can't I can't
get back so he's starting to go that way
it doesn't matter I still reconcile the
energy and you can still be here you can
start increasing slowly and I keep
aiming it down keeping it out of my
shoulder
[Music]
every time I feel a little bite I
release it by doing a kind of corpse
pose do you understand and you're
getting tired
then we go to the other side that's
better so you you want to find my foot
there you go okay
and I hold this and start relaxing he as
I relax he cannot be lulled into relaxed
you understand he'll feel my tension go
like he has to increase his tension the
more I feel his tension the more I let
go of mine
the more he pushes the more that I
release it started really digging you
won't publish the more I release
[Music]
okay got it so you can your will be lost
you'll have to discipline out your the
calibration tool okay
and so just pose to deepen and start
pushing okay let's go you're bracing
rain you're leaning forward get your
chest out
you're too hunched in the shoulders
[Music]
do you have a bracing angle in your
pelvis right right here round out more
not in an exaggerated way
and you push with your back foot
conscious relaxation you'll feel your
mind tense as they push and you
consciously relax
kind of a dynamic corpse pose
so we don't want the bracing angle do
you see that you see I'm gonna
exaggerate but this is a bracing angle
to right and this is a bracing angle
it's my lower back this brace okay so a
way that you tell bracing angles and see
let's go really fast
okay so he's he's gonna load my you're
doing that thing okay he's gonna load my
book in there he's gonna load my back
foot right
keep going and I keep the last drill I
keep relaxing really I want you this as
you guys are coming out of intermediate
I want you to start letting go of that
lower leg that is a problem area so the
lower leg if you can get that then the
next problem area I want you to do is
focus in on the pelvis area start
releasing that without changing the
ankle and then he's pushing and I'm
relaxing he's pushing and I'm relaxing
and he'll let go whenever he wants and
you can see that I don't fly forward do
you see that so that's how you know you
didn't have a bracing angle you had a
ground pop okay alright let's try that
crown of the head mid foot weight keep
all sides of your body alive don't focus
in on the hand that's being grabbed
you're soft in the middle your heel
weighted you can't be heel weighted you
have to be mid foot weight
[Music]
so give him give him your wrist this is
a trick give him your wrist don't put
your arm up like that every trick you do
is every obstacle you make is every time
you don't get it
same thing lower your hand a little bit
Josh point your fingers down a little
there you go so you got some shaking
you gotta consciously relax and you have
to find her back foot you are
calibrating her you are not her enemy
you are her tool to help her
relax the arm she's touching
they said he helps me find it and
because everything was in the back foot
I don't need the front foot ok so he's
gonna help me find the back foot without
losing structure and I can take away
that back foot you can see how I've been
starting to Teeter so no no no that's
too much off right too much off go
helping me and you slowly increase
slowly increase then I'll be the other
side we start with the same thing right
I find the back foot and I'm relaxing
he's pushing he's helping me find it and
I take off push whoa whoa help me help
me push that's too little off more more
MORE slower slower more MORE
[Music]
Oh
- I
[Music]
yeah
you
[Music]
you got your bicep going can have that
that much arm Bend
[Music]
so obviously I'm not breaking right okay
so as because I have one point one point
is really a kind of sphere isn't it
right one point is kind of an axis so it
doesn't really matter where he's pushing
do you understand that that's why you
can see it up nothing
he's pushing right go ahead get get it a
longing that way why your whole body no
I want you to line that one that's it
he's pushing
[Music]
that's usually
push harder
[Music]
they bring back
he gets some wine his Hisle body
alignment everytime push that's it
okay you understand so I'm going to do
it so I'm here like this he finds that
back foot he imagines that he's all in
one leg then I'm going to start taking
it this way do you see how I'm gonna
lining myself for that push do you see
that and then when we come back do you
see how I'm aligning every time aligning
aligning okay
get your head up
this one we're gonna take your failure
slowly increase to failure
[Music]
course
don't pull it forward I want you to
trilateral I want you to come across his
angle at a right angle
[Music]
push from your Center
push triangle to him don't pull him
forward
watch the bend in your arm keep it at
its koko extension release the deltoid
release the pelvis release the lower leg
[Music]
push from your foot the same way who
case doing the same drill
we're doing the same thing same exact
drill of course I can do that one he
gonna touch me anywhere so he's gonna
incrementally move to a different
position go so you'll take this arm
maybe take this arm hold there move up
right maybe I give him my arm and I'm
going to continue that same movement
okay
the same ground path so then you'll go
back out
I'll stay connected and he can stop
anywhere he's still pushing my foot into
the ground as he goes out for moves I
fill the space do you see how I'm doing
that and he can stop anywhere and I find
the movement again that's fine
now if you want to come up right you
have to give me the in space up and I'm
and you can stop one it we're gonna stop
and push in some weird angle you
understand that and then get back to cut
up the donating okay so let's do it
again on this side
I let him do what he wants
I haven't need more pressure
[Music]
or pressure
okay like that
[Music]
get to the body again push on her body
calibrating
[Music]
II
you
[Music]
II
year
[Music]
oh we're lower your Center
you're bracing you're bracing
[Music]
okay so it's not you're not looking for
structural integrity
and that's it you're looking for a
relaxation without a loss of structural
integrity do you understand that
that's not what we want so remember the
order you were given finding the back
foot right then from the back foot start
relaxing
do you remember and then if you start to
lose
he will calibrate or you can calibrate
him okay but the goal was always to find
the relaxation right the relaxation you
understand okay so he goes because
really you can't do anything with it
with that tense structural integrity you
can only do things with the sawed-off
structural integrity so we've done this
one right don't don't move don't move
okay so I want him to go that way do you
remember that one okay so I'm gonna find
the softness and I'm using that
structural integrity to make myself move
as a unit but here do you feel that
Ronin this I started to pull him
Dickstein
and that that's wrong front you see from
the softness the softness not quite
doing this stuff already there is a
capacity to generate the friction it is
body PC so I'm not doing an obvious
thing or an obvious thing there there is
a friction that's happening I have and
it comes from the relaxation so you know
how sometimes you guys your guys don't
move and you're wondering how in the
hell and they get me to move all over
cuz there's the kind of stickiness this
is stickiness that's happening and that
only comes from that relaxed structure
do you understand okay so we're going
back to tonight's training so I have to
really work on the relaxing now here's
what I've seen I've seen tension or
compromise you see
mmm you got to blow yourself up then you
have to relax without letting the
balloon lose hair you got it and without
filling it with cement just start
relaxing relaxing relaxing try to your
point it down you've defined way back to
it please so I do my foot that's it and
then I started relaxing everything
especially those areas I told you foot
lower leg powerless without letting your
upper torso skeleton lose its shape okay
alright let's try that